[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur la
chaîne parlementaire pour ce nouveau
numéro de parlement m dos avec à mes
côtés cathy gilder bonjour khater
bonjour oriane et cette semaine pour
commenter une semaine donc très chargé
nous accueillons jean françois lamour
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député l air
de paris est en charge notamment des
investitures au sein de votre parti pour
les législatives
on va en parler deux temps forts cette
semaine l'installation du nouveau
gouvernement
autant d'hommes que de femmes des
personnalités de la société civile et
des ministres de droite
et puis on évoquera la bataille donc
pour les législatives qui s'annoncent
rudes
on verra notamment comment la droite à
bord de leur rendez vous mais le fait
marquant de cette semaine politique
c'est bien sûr la nomination du
gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi au lendemain de son investiture
emmanuel macron a donc choisi de nommer
un premier ministre de droite edouard
philippe 46 ans député-maire les
républicains due à un très proche
d'alain juppé avec qui il a fait
campagne pendant la primaire
alors jean françois lamour est-ce que ce
choix d'edouard philippe c'est un bon
choix
c'est en quoi un pari de la part du
président de la république effectivement
de vouloir nous démontrer qu'on peut
faire venir des élus de droite personnel
politique de droite sans que ceci est
acté le principe du plan de réforme qui
est proposée il ya encore quelques jours
edouard philippe défendent est la non
augmentation de la csg or là il va
devoir appliquer une augmentation de 1
7% on n'est pas dans l'épaisseur du
trait ces 20 milliards d'impôts nouveaux
un voyage ça serait petites mesures on
pourrait comprendre ça n'est pas renier
ses convictions ça maintenant et on a du
mal à voir la cohérence justement de
cette démarche nous ce qui nous anime
après avoir c'est vrai amende et une
petite partie du projet que nous portons
c'est cette cohérence et c'est
d'ailleurs que nous avions porté pendant
la présidentielle
là on a le sentiment que l'on vient et
puis en garde après je pense pas que ce
soit la meilleure méthode pour assurer
finalement ce que souhaitait le
président de la république est ce que
nous avons d'ailleurs tous compris
franchement c'est à dire essayons de
travailler quand on est d'accord sur un
sujet ensemble au rebond de notre pays
lassés on vient
et puis on regardera après ce qu'on peut
faire je pense pas que ça soit la bonne
méthode très clairement ça trouble un
peu plus ses électeurs je pense qu'ils
auraient préféré avoir les idées claires
choisir finalement une majorité et une
opposition à l'assemblée sur la base de
projets arrivent ensuite les questions
envoyées
jce latif jean-françois l'agent de tenir
ce raid a refilé parce que pour vous il
est encore un homme de droite ça ceux
déjà lui se dit encore homme de droite
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est plutôt
une aventure personnelle
voilà c'est très clairement un parcours
personnel il a quitté de fait les
républicains après est il de droite ou
pas nous nous verrons bien dans sa
démarche effectivement de faire en sorte
de baisser des déficits publics d'éviter
des dépenses supplémentaires d'éviter de
charger les français en matière d'impôts
ces deux là dessus qui va être jugé et
on pourra effectivement dire ensuite si
finalement il a le souvenir de ce que
nous avons porté pour la présidentielle
on va le voir au travail très vite parce
que justement c'est un peu mon
inquiétude là aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
de com il énormément de com alors
certains appellent ça le débauchage
d'autres nouvelles de les ouvertures
vers un certain nombre d'élus de droite
et du centre bon maintenant on veut
vraiment voir si on veut avoir un
concret si vous voulez aujourd'hui la
situation de la france est toujours
exactement même et c'est un peu bizarre
si je peux me permettre c'est qu'on
passe par pertes et profits les 50
monsieur hollande ça ça fait trois
lignes dans les journaux
quelques reportages circulez ya rien à
voir voir c'est un peu dommage parce que
quand même je termine on à 3,7 pour son
déficit
on a une dette de 2 mille milliards
d'euros c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
maintenant que monsieur philippe
cependant en attendant demain en
attendant son propos justement un petit
focus sur la composition de sa nouvelle
équipe aux manettes avec ce sujet dès
l'amont d'un gabarit et on en parle
parité pluralisme politique et
renouvellement le premier gouvernement
d'edouard philippe respecte-t-il les
objectifs fixés par emmanuel macron
sur les 22 ministres et secrétaires
d'état onze femmes et 11 hommes parité
respectée donc à ceci près qu aucune
femme n'a le rang de ministre d'état et
qu'une seule occupe un ministère
régalien sylvie goulard aux armes et
l'égalité homme-femme portefeuille de
marlène schiappa et un secrétariat
d'état et non un ministère de plein
exercice sur le pluralisme politique on
retrouve effectivement des personnalités
de gauche de droite et du centre la plus
grosse prise de guerre à droite et bruno
le maire qui hérite de l'économie les
comptes publics seront tenus par
l'ancien directeur de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy pendant la primaire
gérald darmanin le centre est bien
servie avec des ministères importants
françois bayrou à la justice sylvie
goulard aux armées et marielle de sarnez
aux affaires européennes enfin la gauche
est représentée par les fidèles de la
première heure
gérard collomb à l'intérieur jean yves
le drian aux affaires étrangères richard
ferrand à la cohésion et au territoire
le sénateur jacques mézard à
l'agriculture ainsi que christophe
castaner secrétaire d'état aux relations
avec le parlement et porte parole du
gouvernement
les personnalités issues de la société
civile composent la moitié du
gouvernement
nicolas hulot numéro deux à la
transition écologique et solidaire
l'escrimeuse laura flessel au sport ou
encore l'éditrice françoise nyssen à la
culture
beaucoup de ces personnalités peu
connues du grand public ont des profils
techniques
elisabeth bornes l'ancienne présidente
de la ratp récupère les transports
le nouveau ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer air est un ancien
directeur général de l'enseignement
scolaire la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn a quant à elle dirigeait la haute
autorité de santé
alors jean françois lamour c'est quoi
pour vous ce gouvernement ni de gauche
ni de droite gouvernement de coalition
de rupture comment vous le définir et
c'est tout sauf un gouvernement de
coalition pour moi la coalition c'est
chacun défend ses idées et travaille
ensuite sur une plateforme commune là
c'est un agglomérat de personnalités de
droite du sang avant on nous dit c'est
des meilleurs on va les juger un très
très vite sur ce qu'ils sont en capacité
de faire
avec des priorités qui aujourd'hui on a
du mal à les saisir m'apprend la
priorité c'est l'emploi la priorité
c'est le rebond de l'économie française
aujourd'hui dans la composition du
gouvernement dans l'expression et
compris du premier ministre je ne vois
rien venir danser aujourd'hui très
clairement un gouvernement qui doit
donner en tout cas monsieur macron le
souhaitent une majorité et qui doit lui
donner une majorité à l'assemblée c'est
simplement ça on nous dit que ce
gouvernement est fait pour durer
nous nous verrons à l'usagé mais j'ai
pas eu le sentiment vraiment que ce
gouvernement là tels que nous nous
l'avions proposé est tout de suite prêt
c'est un pari risqué de prendre des
profits de ces différents pour vous
c'est risqué parce que par définition on
peut craindre la cacophonie ou alors ou
alors c'est simplement pour le paysage
et tout va se faire réaliser c'est
encore pire
on a le sentiment quand même à regarder
le profil des conseillers autour de
monsieur macron leur origine leur
parcours très inspecteur des finances et
n'a pas l'impression qu'on retrouve
effectivement un un modèle assez
classique finalement on nous avait
annoncé un ouvre un renouvellement de la
vie politique et quand on voit à la fois
la composition de gouvernement et le
mode de fonctionnement de l'elysée
y'a rien de bien moqué nouveau quand
même c'est qu'il est composé à moitié de
membres de la société civile à moitié
deux politiques vous même vous veniez de
la société civile vous est annoncé en
grand sportif de haut niveau est ce que
vous saluer ce choix à ceci près tu peux
parce que vous citez bon exemple
à ceci près que j'avais travaillé sept
ans auprès de jacques chirac comme
conseiller technique j'avais appris ce
que c'était effectivement qu'une
interministériel qu'une relation au sein
d'un gouvernement avec a déjà une
expérience avec quelque part vous savez
très bien des arbitrages très lourds en
particulier en matière de budget et de
ressources humaines
nous jouons encore une fois mais je je
je jette pas la pierre je dis simplement
que la société est bien positionnée sur
des dossiers un membre de la société
civile mais qui n'a jamais fait de
politique à vendre ses parts dont il
peut avoir aussi un bon cabinet faute
bien joué mais j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les cabinets sont
essentiellement imposé par l'elysée pour
ça je vous dis que ce casting du
gouvernement laisse entendre que tout va
se décider
en tout cas une très très grande partie
à l'elysée et ça on sait c'est hyper
présidence c'est pas très bon pour le
pays
et on sait ça peut nous amener
effectivement très rapidement dans une
impasse en parlant de personnalités de
la société civile il ya donc nicolas
hulot qui fait son entrée dans le
gouvernement qui aura devant lui
notamment le dossier notre dame des
landes est ce que vont penser qu'il
arrivera à la divine et ce dossier
explosif je vous dis après du mal à
comprendre sa position
c'est un dossier qui va être traité à
l'elysée alors vous n'avez vu que si on
était reparti sur une commune nouvelle
commission sonné les médiateurs là c'est
un peu le ça passe au dessus de la tête
de nicolas hulot c'est ce que je vous
dis moi je suis intimement convaincu que
une très grande partie des dossiers vont
être réalisés c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle parce que de fait on on a
compris que quand on concentre est
beaucoup trop de pouvoir réaliser dans
le modèle de la 5ème encore une fois
faut respecter notre modèle de
constitution je ne pense pas que ça
apporte beaucoup d'élan et dynamique sur
nicolas hulot mama jugera effectivement
des premiers et des premiers exercices
gouvernementaux c'est pour ça c'est
important
je pense qu'on va aborder ça tout à
l'heure qu'il nous faut une assemblée
qui ne soit pas une assemblée lui doigt
sur la couture du montana finir sur
nicolas hulot c'est quand même une belle
prise de guerre pour emmanuel macron il
a réussi là où jacques chirac et nicolas
sarkozy ont échoué finale puis aussi
peut être c'est que monsieur hulot
estime qu'il est aujourd'hui mature pour
rentrer dans un gouvernement il a dû
comprendre aujourd'hui que pouvait
l'être les obstacles aussi un quand on
était au sein d'un gouvernement
l'idée aussi qu'il faut faire preuve de
cohésion et pas simplement d'avoir une
vision si elle n'est pas partagée
est ce qu'il aura les moyens la latitude
pour défendre cette idée selon vous
savez c'est laisser les sujets convient
d'évoquer mon avis effectivement c'est
que beaucoup de choses ont décidé à
l'elysée mais je viens dialysés même pas
à matignon
or j'entendais monsieur macron dire je
serai président et ce serait le
gouvernement gouverner c'est un peu la
mode de jacques chirac un souvenez ou en
tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant est dit qu il sera un
président qui préside et que c'est le
gouvernement qui gouverne chaise en deux
temps au vue de l'organisation du
gouvernement du choix effectivement de
ses conseillers à l'elysée que beaucoup
de choses du choix des directeurs de
cabinet celles et ceux qui arrivent au
sein de ce gouvernement que beaucoup de
choses se décideront évidemment à
l'elysée il ya trois modèles qui ont
fait leur entrée au gouvernement
est-ce que c'est beaucoup ou pas par
rapport à leur poids souvenez vous
monsieur mathieu béraud nous avait dit
il ya pas de nego rien on s'est vraiment
l'élan du coeur
et puis on a vu quand même un petit
teigneux kit épisode pas très
réjouissant meurt pas très reluisant sur
les accords en particulier en matière de
sièges à l'assemblée nationale souvenez
vous on était un peu dans des comptes
d'apothicaire et je pense que dans le
deal global
il y avait aussi la l'entrée d'un
certain nombre de membres du modem au
gouvernement voilà donc ça fait parti
d'un dit global d'envoyer canton ne pas
de renouvellement de la vie politique
qu'il faut s'attacher à ce genre de
détails pour finalement se rendre compte
que c'est oui un peu comme avant mais il
ya quand même quelque chose de nouveau
il ya un tandem à bercy ces nouveaux
donc gérard darmana est bonne et bruno
le maire ça vous surprend ce que c'est
un duo qui peut fonctionner à il a
intérêt pour le pays d'intérêt
fonctionnez vous en conviendrez
premièrement or vous allez avoir
un ministre du budget pour faire court
darmanin qui lui va devoir répondre aux
sollicitations des membres du
gouvernement et puis un ministre de
l'économie qui lui va essayer de
verrouiller lancé ça dépend ça va
extrêmement difficile alors la
constitution de ce nouvel exécutif et
des remous à droite chez vous les
premières exclusions sont tombés même si
la droite fait bloc
françois baroin en campagne aux côtés
d'alain juppé les croissances l'objectif
affiché par les deux hommes
allié de circonstance présenter le
visage d'un parti uni à trois semaines
des législatives
parler de réconciliation supposerait
qu'il était brouille
je n'ai pas le souvenir qu'il ya du
groupe
l'heure est donc au rassemblement chez
les républicains
une unité face aux tentations macro nien
dernier en date l'entrée de bruno le
maire et de gérald darmanin au
gouvernement il ya des personnalités de
qualité
certaines sont issus de nos rangs c'est
un choix personnel
en fait on va pas je les respecte ce
sont des démarches individuelles
c'est une mauvaise analyse politique de
notre point de vue et ça n'était en rien
une coalition des nominations perçue par
françois baroin comme des prises
d'otages isolés comme le projette en
marche porte sur une augmentation de la
csg
ça veut dire pour vous la droite
représenter un quart de l'augmentation
des impôts
on va profiter quand même de cette
campagne pour dire que nous on est
plutôt sur la bd a poussé sa nos projets
des accusations réfutées par le nouveau
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
gérald darmanin sur ces nominations de
bruno le maire et gérald darmanin quand
on entend françois baroin a parlé de
prise d'otage est ce que l'expression
n'est pas trop forte pour donner
l'exemple de bruno le maire moi je ne
fais pas mal suivi
alors que vous savez j'étais au côté de
françois fillon mais j'ai suivi dans
dans la campagne pour la primaire est
très clairement à la mi 2016 il se
voyait faiseur de rois souvenez vous on
le donnait à 20 % de votes en sa faveur
puis s'est retrouvé à 2% je pense que là
ça a été une vraie rupture n'est pas
finalement si je comprends bien j'ai
rien à faire dans cette famille
politique et je pense que depuis cette
fin novembre où finalement il s'est
retrouvé derrière nathalie kosciusko
morizet en termes de résultats il est
parti il n'était plus là déjà il était
plus avec nous donc il a fait campagne
parce qu'il est faire campagne et vous
avez vu que très très vite il s'est
désolé tu dis là il l'a quittée mais de
françois fillon puis de nous tous faut
bien dire aussi des choses comme elles
sont donc voilà il suit une aventure
personnelle
il estime que c'est son heure c'est son
âge un peu le cas aussi de darmanin je
me souviens de son ajustement repos
qu'il a tenus il a dix mois à 34 ans il
faut que je serai ministre il ya eu des
ministres c'est penser de ce soit
finalement de là ce sont des avants
delhi qui a travaillé avec vous oui oui
et puis d'ailleurs gérald darmanin qui
critiquait très fortement marcangeli
très fortement chantois des termes polis
l'augmentation de la csg
et puis là qui va l'appliquer donc voyez
il ya une forme de contradiction
elle est assez classique sur ceux qui
ont des parcours personnels à honorer
avec une vision de ce que doit être
effectivement leur engagement politique
dont taxes et c'est là où on en revient
tout à l'heure à cette idée de
gouvernement de coalition c'est pas une
coalition
c'est un choix essentiellement en
faisant venir gérald les personnalités
mais vous coûter dans la commission
nationale d'investiture c'est donc lui
qui a choisi avec vous les candidats
aient l'air et eu des et d'autres
personnes nées entre autres et qu'elle
choisit les candidats à l'air et eu des
législatives et là il va faire campagne
contre les candidats qu'il a choisi quel
est le message que vous envoyé aux
électeurs de droite et ben c'est surtout
un d'hermann qu'il faut poser la
question est est ce que je veux dire
quel est le problème vous aussi non
parce que déjà je pense que les
électeurs ont bien compris que c'était
encore une fois plutôt des aventures
personnelles ses électeurs même s'ils
sont troublés moi je le sens 1 sur mon
territoire
évidemment évidemment jouer de quoi je
ne je ne mésestime pas effectivement 7
inquiétude aussi c'est une forme
d'attentisme en liant bas qu'est ce que
ça va donner tout ça enfin ils se
trompent pas sur les deux de nos
collègues qui sont entrés au
gouvernement ils voient bien que c'est
essentiellement pour toi valoriser des
parcours individuels plus le trouble ne
peut pas se transformer en voix en se
disant bain puisque edouard philippe est
de droite il est à matignon après tout
pourquoi pas soutenir ce gouvernement
c'est ce qu'on entend je vous dis pas le
contraire évidemment mais je pense que
c'est franchement déjà première une
petite frange de nos électeurs et encore
une fois regarder des quelques sondages
ces mêmes électeurs disent qu'ils ne
sont pas obligatoirement très très
confiance à ce gouvernement
donc attendant puis nous soyons surtout
très solide sur nos notre projet et nos
convictions
là on parle beaucoup effectivement de la
composition du gouvernement
mais on a un projet je pense que ce
projet reste dans une vraie puissance et
cohérence c'est à nous de le faire
valoir puis surtout d'expliquer que
avoir une majorité une assemblée le
petit doigt sur la couture du pantalon
c'est une erreur manifeste manifeste à
gauche non plus jean françois lamour ce
nouveau gouvernement ne plaît pas à tout
le monde à commencer par jean christophe
cambadélis le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
audrey vue états une fois n'est pas
coutume à gauche tout le monde s'accorde
pour qualifier le premier gouvernement
d'edouard philippe de gouvernement de
droite
il ya d'abord ceux qui fustigent le
tandem à l'économie en choisissant de
confier bercy à bruno le maire et gérald
darmanin le premier ministre edouard
philippe aura l'assurance de pouvoir
mener une politique économique de droite
et en même temps de droite même position
chez benoît hamon qui regrette un
nouveau gouvernement attendu est
composée de libéraux aux ministères clés
quant à l'arrivée de onze personnes pour
représenter la société civile
je remarque qu'elle ait beaucoup recruté
dans ce gouvernement dans les cabinets
ministériels dans les milieux d'affaires
mais la société
la vraie c'est à dire celle du monde du
travail celles qui gagnent moins de 3000
euros
moins de 2000 ou moins de 1800 euros par
mois comme le sont la grande majorité
des français
et bien tout cela ne sont pas
représentés dans le gouvernement
inquiétude aussi sur la représentation
des enjeux écologiques et ce malgré
l'arrivée de nicolas hulot la fameuse
prise de guerre d' emmanuel macron
nicolas hulot là il est bien seul dans
ce gouvernement
le maire à l'économie il est temps qu'il
est rentier colo darmanin au budget
également le nouveau ministre de
l'agriculture n'a rien d'un écolo et
encore une fois faudra des députés
écologistes pour l'appuyer c'est pour ça
qu'on se présente
et là encore toutes les forces de gauche
partagent un objectif peser sur les
législatives pour changer la couleur du
gouvernement alors jean françois lamour
dans ce gouvernement il n'y a pas un
membre du ps excepté ceux qui ont
rejoint emmanuel baron dès le début donc
emmanuel macron montre qu'il n'est pas
vraiment véritablement le l'héritier de
françois hollande
oui il faut qu'il fasse beaucoup
d'efforts pour le montrer c'est tout
l'enjeu est effectivement de cette
composition mais sa trompe personne
encore une fois il va être jugé sur les
actes sur un projet d'ailleurs qui
ressemble beaucoup à celui de monsieur
hollande on sait pas exactement on va
vous parler de monsieur hollande quand
même on a passé ses cinq années par
pertes et profits
pas un bilan rien on passe comme si
finalement on n'avait pas vécu ces cinq
années
un peu surprenant quand même vous
trouvez pas et fort que des trains c'est
la force de monsieur macron alors qu'il
en a été le conseiller et le ministre
que de passer aussi rapidement sur cinq
années terribles pour le pays or c'est
bien là dessus d'ailleurs que monsieur
mac on va rencontrer mon oeil son
premier obstacle
monsieur hollande avant de partir de
l'elysée a engagé près de 12 milliards
de dépenses supplémentaires non
financées on va voir d'ailleurs et le
maire et et darmanin nous expliquer
comment ils vont faire soit pour retirer
le tapis sous les pieds de ce qui avait
été décidé soit pour encore une fois
payé mais qui paye et à quelle cuisine
des impôts supplémentaires
où vont-ils trouver l'argent cinq ans
c'est le temps d'un quinquennat ce aussi
le temps d'une législature on avec le
cap sur les élections législatives très
dans moins d'un mois on connaîtra le
visage de la nouvelle assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et tous les partis et c'est évidemment
de peser dans cette nouvelle assemblée à
commencer par la république en marche
qui essaie de réussir son pari avoir une
majorité absolue
les explications dels monts un cabas
après l'élection présidentielle
la nomination du premier ministre et la
composition du gouvernement
c'est la bataille des législatives qui
s'ouvre pour emmanuel macron un défi de
taille pour celui qui prétend recomposer
le paysage politique
le premier enjeu de ces élections
s'étaient les investitures et la premier
couac au moment même de l'annoncé des
noms des premiers candidats
le modem de françois bayrou ce sont les
et il a fallu rectifier le tir en
investissant des candidats centristes
supplémentaire même s'il ne respecte pas
totalement les critères fixés par en
marche
finalement il n'y aura pas 577
candidature mais 521 les socialistes et
les républicains macron compatible ont
été préservés c'est le cas de manuel
valls stéphane le foll ou encore franck
riester et thierry solère et puis il ya
forcément les déçus plus de vingt mille
dossiers de candidature déposés
parmi eux celui d'alain qu'elle met
l'ancien député ps du cantal
il avait rallié emmanuel macron dès le
soir de la victoire de benoît hamon à la
primaire mais il n'est pas récompensé
pour son soutien il y a aussi le pari de
la société civile plus de 50 % des
candidats ils se sont retrouvés lors
d'un séminaire
une semaine après l'élection d' emmanuel
macron pour aller sur les bancs des
mystiques ça je suis prête
je suis prête pour faire la campagne
j'ai surtout hâte d'aller convaincre les
gens sur les marchés faire des réunions
les rencontrer mais les électeurs feront
ils confiance à ses novices en politique
les partis classiques espère que les
français choisiront l'expérience enfin
les premières décisions du président
macron seront scrutées par les électeurs
elle pourrait influencer le scrutin
alors majorité absolue relative aux
cohabitation réponse les 11 et 18 juin
prochains
les députés élus auront l'obligation de
s'inscrire dans le groupe majoritaire
auparavant ils ont signé un contrat avec
la nation pour montrer leur accord avec
le projet d' emmanuel macron ce que le
nouveau président ne veut surtout pas ce
sont des frondeurs dans son propre camp
alors question simple d'abord jean
françois lamour est ce que vous pensez
que les français donneront à emmanuel
macron une majorité pour gouverner c'est
à dire entre 280 et 300 sondage les
français s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur
la meilleure façon de redresser le pays
ils ont eu à faire un président de la
république qui leur a proposé un projet
qui n'est pas dont la visibilité n'est
pas aussi évidente que ça je pense
aujourd'hui vraiment ils s'interrogent
sur la meilleure façon de redresser le
pays sur la base de leur conviction de
leur choix aussi personnelle un très
très clairement aussi et puis de leur
intérêt et cette décision elle va être
prise au tout dernier moment pour donc à
nous de faire valoir l'intérêt je parle
pour les républicains mais aussi le
centre à la fois de parlementaires qui
sont tout à fait disposés quand c'est
nécessaire à aller dans le sens d'un sa
norme de mesure mais qui sont en
revanche très rigoureux sur deux ou
trois critères que nous allons défendre
c'est à dire pas de hausses d'impôts un
vrai rebond en matière de compétitivité
de nos entreprises et sur ces deux
sujets là très clairement faut bien lire
nous sommes en opposition avec les
propositions de monsieur votre objectif
vous combien de députés espérer vous
revoir du digeon savez très bien que
c'est extrêmement difficile à dire
aujourd'hui majorité absolue majorité
absolue non on a aucune prévision
aujourd'hui on voit des sondages mais
jamal jarrah
150 députés pour le parti socialiste
quel est votre objectif c'est c'est un
chiffre ambitieux faut bien le
reconnaître il est très difficile de
dire les choses dont je ne vais pas me
lancer dans des pronostics très bien en
plus que chaque territoire et
particuliers est ce que c'est un sortant
qui se représente pas en sortant bien
implanté tout ça va jouer également dans
le rapport des électeurs avec eux avec
cette élection ces élections
législatives donc je vous donnerai pas
de suivre simplement à nous de
convaincre et je reconnais qu'il ya
encore du travail à faire pendant ces
trois semaines avant le premier tour à
nous convaincre les français que rien ne
serait pire
j'ai même pas pâle et d'inexpérience
mais d'une assemblée nationale qu'il
soit en capacité de s'opposer quand
c'est nécessaire
un certain nombre de mesures portées par
le gouvernement c'est pas une question
de fronde ou pas penser simplement la
vie démocratique de notre pays
droite gauche on nous dit que ça
n'existe plus peut-être mais bonne ou
mauvaise mesure est ce qu'on est
d'accord pour continuer à débattre de sa
l'assemblée si c'est pas car si c'est
pas car autant faire disparaître
l'assemblée le sénat ait laissé le
président président est tout seul vous
ayez bien cela
ça s'appelle une dictature a continué à
parler cette question des législatives
et je crois qu'il est important
justement de rappeler aux électeurs que
nous sommes en capacité à la fois de
porter des mesures qu'on nous les
estimons bol je l'avais fait d'ailleurs
lors de la précédente mandature avec le
vote de la loi de programmation
militaire actualisé parce que j'estimais
que nos militaires avaient besoin le
matériel supplémentaire mais on peut
aussi cette question des visas
justement c'est l'heure d'accueillir
notre partenaire du figaro.fr team géré
assez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour un yann jean ketcha bonjour jean
françois lamour jeu on a parlé de bruno
le match ou alors vous avez décidé
d'investir un candidat face à lui
est ce que vous avez décidé de thil
s'agit aujourd'hui j'attends les toutes
dernières réponses de chacun des ventes
on a fait ce qu'on appelle une scène
virtuelle je vais partir avec la
validation du secrétaire-général un mail
circulaire auprès de chacun des membres
de la ceni j'attends effectivement les
prochaines heures avant le tueur
évidemment il était on l'attend vraiment
on sera on aura la réponse dans les
toutes prochaines adaptations avant la
fin de la dda face à la date limite
étant ce soir on aurait évidemment cette
mais pontdemé il y aura effectivement un
candidat c'est quoi la place et donc de
le faire battre dans sa circonscription
et du coup dé facto qui quitte le
gouvernant puisque c'est la règle pour
les ministres et c'est surtout de
démontrer que bruno le maire ne fait
plus partie de la famille s'en est lui
même éloignés et alors juste comme ça
pour essayer d'avoir une remarque de bon
sens le présent de la république et
d'ailleurs et doit fip ont dit qu'ils
allaient faire campagne
donc ils vont faire campagne contre nos
candidats donc il est tout à fait normal
que monsieur le maire est-ce que les
souhaité qu'ils soient abattus c'est à
dire est ce que vous allez mettre en
candidat qui soit en possession de le
battre moi je ne souhaite rien je dis
simplement que la logique veut qu'il y
ait effectivement un candidat qui
défendent nos valeurs puisque bruno le
maire va aller partout en france pour
faire campagne contre nos candidats
alors c'est quand même la russie un peu
particulier de nous expliquer qu'il faut
l'union nationale qu'ils m'ont doit être
assemblé que la première des choses
qu'il va faire ils feraient mieux de
redresser le pays
ces damnés ne restera pas d'un outil
nouveau candidat il ya une autre
candidate pied qui est concurrencé à
paris cette fois ci il s'agit de
nathalie kosciusko morizet qui a
également fait des appels du pied envers
macron il ya
le maire du 6e arrondissement jean
pierre lecoq qui se présente face à
lille réclame l'investiture des
républicains était le rapport ne leur a
pas surnommé en tout cas il ya deux
tendances
il sera suspendu d'ailleurs sera là la
procédure est engagée tout à fait vous
dénoncez sa candidature dissidente bien
en tant que président de la ceni mois
j'investis des candidats il faut que cet
accord soit respectée et c'est le
secrétaire général bernard accoyer qui
compte cet accord n'est pas respectée
don king a séduit va être lancée tout
comme c'est pas simplement ce cas là et
on en a quelques autres peu nombreux et
on en a quelques autres partout en
france
parlons votre cas personnel vous
présentait donc dans le 15e
arrondissement et en vous vous n'avez
pas été épargné puisque en marche
présente face à vous une rançon
c'est un ancien chiraquien comme vous
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça fait
finalement défier aussi de la
comparaison est simplement n'est pas
vous demand du même clan politique rené
déjà clan c'est pas le terme mais vous
savez je suis de vous dire une chose
faut arrêter de faire parler monsieur
jacques chirac encore aujourd'hui vous
savez très bien
il n'est pas en mesure de dire à certain
nombre de choses je sais pas s'ils
étaient en capacité de le dire ce qu'ils
penseraient tout ça donc mémé dans les
jolis laisser l'autre côté mon corps
alors au tirage si je peux mais il ya
une confiance respecter le d'accord très
regardé après regardez notation ne s'est
pas vous que je dis c'est aux électeurs
regardez les parcours ce qui est vrai et
ce qui est vrai c'est que moi je pense
que les électeurs ont besoin et feront
confiance à des parlementaires
expérimentés justement pour porter la
contradiction quand elle est nécessaire
et pour voter des textes quand
effectivement ces textes sont bons pour
le pays voilà en tout cas ce pourquoi je
m'engage et ben merci ce sera le mot de
la fin
jean françois lamour merci d'avoir été
notre invité merci katia et à dans deux
semaines
[Musique]